you laugh
well at least laugh track did but how is
this skull any different than most of
the deco madness going on in this place
this face vase has flowers growing out
of its head i don't know what's going on
with this woman and her dog
in this stovetop chef is clearly a
serial killer my point is this goal is
basically norm core for this crew
letting your clipboard pencil dangle
skull
oh yeah it's my mom's oh my god i had no
recollection of how many times the show
makes jokes surrounding the death of
phoebe's mom but based on the seven or
eight episodes i've sinned
it's at least way too many times did you
know i was in there
no how long have we been home
about a half an hour i think the
concerning part of this equation is that
it doesn't appear the door was ever
closed
also hemorrhoids when we get married are
you gonna uh
change your last name to bing microsoft
groupies
things weird google groupies i know what
probably really means
yeah yeah oh your mom probably won't
kill herself
that is the second joke about phoebe's
mom's death in under three minutes bet
you're taking back that nasty youtube
comment you already published about how
i was exaggerating when i brought it up
the first time huh
hi could we get two burritos to go
please
laughing at your own joke we have a
reservation under the name chandler bing
okay we'll have a table for you in about
45 minutes
45 minutes but they have a reservation
this restaurant clearly follows the
seinfeld laws of knowing how to take
reservation but not knowing how to hold
one
you need to give him money bribing the
restaurant host is the side plot of your
sitcom cliche
everybody wants a payoff all right calm
down o'malley
unless i'm missing some extremely
obscure reference that's racist
had the money in the wrong hand this
moment falls into both the mistakes only
dumb sitcom characters make and
jokes only laughtrack's laugh at
categories chandler being with a line
drive double right up the middle
you don't feel like you're gonna throw
up do you the question i ask myself
every time i have to watch scenes of
ross attempting fatherhood somehow makes
it into this episode
santa has rangers that can fly but if i
can trust the internet
and really how could you not his
reindeer aren't born with the ability to
fly but are fed especially concocted
reindeer food made from magical fungi so
rudolph and the gang are basically using
performance-enhancing drugs and this
really shouldn't be all that impressive
thank you got there put it there
definitely not easier with coins at some
point in this series chandler went from
being the lovable funny friend to the
one that is certifiably insane
i'm honestly not sure which one i like
more which probably is a sin on me but
still is in
thank you thank you stealing you got
joey drums to annoy rachel how did
monica not already realize this after
the conversation she had with phoebe
earlier she deserves to have the last
name being
it died because my cat ate it yeah my
cat died the circle of life
phoebe did you get all this stuff for
joey to try and drive me out of the
apartment
this episode is 37 characters coming to
this exact realization
monica asked me to make the drumming
stop
done true how will joey ever manage to
find anything else that could be used to
hit the drums
everyone knows each drum kit contains
bluetooth connected sticks that only
work with the kit they were enclosed
with
hello sir you here to return those pants
no but the writer should have returned
that joke
he's wearing straight up normal khakis
where is funny i'm the
holiday armadillo roll commercials
also armadillo costumes do exist but
they also seem like the costume that
your friend chad would wear to your
halloween party as a joke and then the
night wore on and the tequila shots
increase and dad would piss himself in
it amongst other things he would never
return it and you would lose the 300
you loaned him for the deposit so what
i'm saying is the costume shop would be
more likely to have a santa costume or
something that's at least red and green
and feels more christmassy than they
would the bladder splattered armadillo
costume
also chad texas
that's right ben i'm santa's
representative for
all the southern states
so why would you be in new york how did
ross even get to monica in chandler's
apartment there's no way you rode in a
cab wearing that and if you walk down
the street
well it's new york city so no one would
have even thought twice most likely so i
guess this is a sin for new york city
pay more attention people what if the
holiday armadillo told you all about the
festival of lights cool ross's
armadillos now barely covers his face
and he's making very little effort to
hide his voice
if ben doesn't realize this is his dad
perhaps they should be having a
conversation about the festival of
optometrists
you called everyone and said you were
having trouble finding a santa costume
so i borrowed one from a guy at work
and instead of calling you i decided to
wear it and surprise ben myself because
these hijinks aren't just gonna ensue
themselves
i'm finally getting him excited about
hanukkah and then you're you're wrecking
it
pretty sure ross is wrecking it because
ben is less than 20 feet away from them
and could hear this entire conversation
remember um remember how you told me
that your grandmother put up that wall
to make that into two bedrooms
yeah and remember how you always said
you were afraid that the landlord would
find out and then tear it down
how how's the landlord never found this
out how would you even have a wall put
up in an apartment without the
landlord's knowledge
my it's new york city no one pays
attention to blinders can only be put on
so many times people
my favorite part was when superman flew
all the jews out of egypt
man these dc universe crossover events
just keep getting stranger and stranger
the armadillo was actually not so
thrilled about that part
i'm not so thrilled about the part where
ben now probably thinks monica is
cheating on chandler with santa claus
look how [ __ ] cozy she is with him on
the couch
hey spiders aren't scary make sure you
click that bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click it
sell outs no but um she probably does
oh probably so you're telling me there's
a chance
okay we'll have a table for you in about
45 minutes
we were hoping to get here earlier
actually get a table
i didn't quite make it did you you don't
feel like you're gonna throw up do you
i'm fine i just uh threw up in my mouth
a little bit
joy you know that you could just not
throw the sticks up in the air
what is rock and roll about that i don't
think anyone can really
explain rock and roll maybe pete
townsend
hello sir you here to return those pants
why would you say something so
controversial yet so brave
happy birthday you think you can keep it
another night
call me santa shut up
spit on me